foreign
yes congratulations so uh how can we
help
okay so I need your help because
I do not know how to budget my money
um my husband has done a great job of
providing for our family
he worked at a wonderful job for 10
years and was let go in 2018
and since then he has been working on
the project
where he wants to develop a golf aid for
golfers and so he's been working on that
can I can I interject here
yeah so he got let go in 2018 and he's
had a big idea for uh five years five
years and has made no money and probably
put y'all in a hole
yeah so well no we're not in a hole yet
but that's why I'm calling to prevent
that getting close okay yeah so he like
I said we had we had quite a bit of
money in savings and we've been living
off of that oh yeah um he has
successfully started a company before
and it's a wonderful company y'all have
probably heard of it
um but I won't mention it but anyway
um he's trying to do it again and we
have about eighty thousand dollars left
and he I every time I ask him I'm like
can you he's I'm the spender he's the
favor and so when we have Financial
discussions it usually goes something
like this Laura you need to stop
spending money and I'm like well I can't
because we have a family so give me a
budget he's like well just don't spend
money where we don't need to
how about you make some
yeah
no yeah you should you should say that
really it's been five years Laura I know
I know we did have we did have a
financial conversation two weeks ago and
they told him if by June this hasn't
taken off then I want you to get a job
or I want to sell our home so we have
um we bought our house back in 20. okay
hey Laura do this this is uh this is too
important of a call because too many
people are experiencing this across the
country all right so I'm gonna run back
through your uh what's going on and we
can start here and let me know if I'm
missing something
um you and your husband had a great job
things were awesome y'all we're cruising
along and then he got laid off in 2018
and he's an entrepreneur he's built a
really successful business before and he
had another great idea to help golfers
um and
I think golfers need a lot of help but
that's a whole other conversation and so
he decided he's going to help golfers
and then we look up and it's 2023 the
business isn't making money y'all have
basically
set fire to your savings and now there's
starting to be some the the there's some
tension in the home pressure yeah we are
get
yeah
the conversations are turning into hey
you need to quit spending money him to
you right yeah and you'll have 80 grand
left
yeah what is he what does he bring in a
year
uh so nothing so literally nothing
it's literally nothing 10 20. so he got
a large severance package and that was
2018 2019 and then
um nothing's been since then nothing
nothing nothing
so we had a large large savings and we
have no debt aside from our mortgage
what y'all's living expenses Laura if
you if you said okay you know we spend
how much a year yeah if you could
estimate a year oh gosh
probably 120 maybe 100 like yeah this is
this is embarrassing because I am the
sender and I'm just like I don't know
how much I spend because if we need it I
buy it
um and that yeah yeah and that's how you
guys have been functioning yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I right right before
we went to the break I said this isn't a
money issue there's something way deeper
here
um
I'm gonna be super honest okay is that
cool
I'm worried about the future of y'alls
I'm worried about the future of y'all's
marriage
here's why I think that if you were to
be really honest with yourself you're
losing respect for your husband or it's
gonna start rolling into from
frustration
to I'm just going to live my life and
he'll tell me to you're gonna end up in
resentment and relational resentment is
really tough to come back from that's
the ash
and he on the other hand is going to
wrap himself up in shame his thing's not
working he's got another deal and then
maybe another deal I just need this one
thing to come through and all of a
sudden he looks up and it's been five
years and he's gonna tighten the control
up and that's going to come out on you
and he's going to resent his crazy
spinning wife who just doesn't
understand he just needs one more break
and you see what I'm saying and you all
start living separate lives in the same
home and I've said it you end up two
inches apart but two thousand miles away
from each other and that's a recipe for
a whole lot of issues
is that fair no I've listened to your
story
and
[Music]
and listen to your radio show before and
there have been many times where I've
been like yep that's us
yeah and so I am I I am trying though
and so absolutely absolutely I did I
well I I did put boundaries in place I
may need to adjust those boundaries he
is
um he did acquiesce to my
boundary of getting a job by June
um but
I think my
my main questions like where do we go
from here we have this house we have
about 415 approximately because I don't
know how much it would sell for if we
could sell it but we have 415 in equity
in the house
you're trying to solve a math problem
yeah it's not a house problem it's an
income problem I mean that's what it is
and so the house isn't the thing that
that is you know out of whack I mean
obviously you guys have a mortgage and
so you're like oh I have to actually pay
the mortgage and we don't have you know
the money is coming out of savings and
so you know on a tactical level Laura
not just the relational because that's
kind of what John was hitting on
on a tactical level I'm going to give
you uh Financial Peace University for a
year and every dollar and I want you
guys to sit down together and I think
actually seeing numbers and go back and
pull grocery numbers from the last three
months restaurants like everything you
spend money on because there is this
level of I don't really know and that
fear starts to magnify when you don't
have logic John always says facts are
your friends so I think just even just
for today just a practical step when it
comes to the money piece is for you and
I would say you to do it
um to do the budget first and then you
guys sit down and look at it but I think
that's going to give you a guiding post
because you're able to say okay we spend
uh ten thousand dollars we need ten
thousand dollars a month to keep our
lifestyle without dipping into savings
how do we solve that problem right you
can tactically start you know hitting
that which is going to give you a level
of Peace because you are terrified right
I mean and anyone would Laura I mean
what you've watched savings time for you
for the last five years so so you're not
crazy you're not you're not this like oh
I'm over the top dramatic no this is
this is real life you have four boys you
know you're a mom and you're looking at
grocery bills and all of it and so
you're and you've been doing that on
your own as well which is what it sounds
like and so he needs to see the numbers
realistically of of what is going on
because this whole idea of oh you just
can't you know just stop spending and
you're like no literally there's like a
sports fee for him to place out like I
have to pay that like there are things
yeah like there are actual things that I
have to spend and I want him to see
these numbers because you've been on an
island Laura in a lot of different ways
emotionally in lots of ways but
financially you have been and so I want
to bring him in uh to that conversation
and you guys start and I want you guys
to go through Financial Peace University
together I think it's just a great
springboard it's getting you on the same
page when it comes to the money piece
and what's wild and I don't know which
comes first the chicken or the egg John
but we hear people all the time say gosh
we started working together with our
money and suddenly our marriage improved
for some people they're like no we
needed our marriage to improve and then
we worked on the money together right I
I don't know which one's first I don't
even know if there's a truth that's kind
of like that chicken or egg thing
um but they both are so deeply
intertwined
um so let me tell you how I would enter
this conversation if I'm you Laura I
this is I I would put the you have to
get a job by June
that is a tactic that comes later
the first conversation is sitting down
and saying we need to have a hard
conversation and you look at him and say
I'm scared to death and I can't breathe
I think the problem is that I'm not
scared because I know I know that's
going to sound crazy I grew up without a
lot and so I feel like it would not be
the worst thing in the world for me I
actually think it'd be a little good for
our boys to learn less entitlement like
our boys live in a big house
have a lot of things and they just think
that that's how life goes and I'm like
no you don't understand like okay those
are boundaries Laura you can put in
place as a parent regardless of your
financial examination it doesn't need to
be out of the desperation don't use your
boys don't use your kids
as an excuse to tell your husband you
want to move
don't do that don't use your kids as an
excuse to tell your husband I don't
respect you anymore Jim had a job in
five years and a common trap with
entrepreneurs especially ones that are
successful right out of the gate is
they're really good at the thing they
did that they sell and it becomes really
good and they think that they're good at
building businesses they may have just
been really good at Plumbing or they may
have been really good at selling online
whatever and it doesn't translate all
the time and you get stuck like you're
spinning your tires in the mud right and
so you might not be scared
but you're losing faith in this guy
yeah I think that
that yeah John I think you're right I
it's more fear for my relationship than
it is for the money and the house and
all the stuff I'm like I want to be
you're going to be married there you go
in five years Laura that's where you
started I want to be married that's
where you start
not with you got to get a job not your
lazy bum and not it is I want to be
married to you in five years and I think
that the foundation underneath this is
cracking underneath
and I love you too much